c'est vrai
et s'habiller avec les yeux décoller
ce spandex
arrêter ce n'est pas ce que je fais ces
rivages sont si serrés que vous pouvez voir que son
petit mec porte aussi un petit casque de banque d'
accord vous semblez bouleversé eh bien mes affaires sont
dans les toilettes
je  je n'ai pas d'assurance oh je peux à peine
payer mes factures oh
allez aujourd'hui ma voiture a été
reprise à part ça
je suis incroyable
il est temps pour vous de vous retrouver face à face
avec qui vous êtes
et ce dont vous êtes capable qu'est-ce que c'est
placez la réponse à tous
vos problèmes
est-ce que vous vous moquez de moi c'est un refuge un
refuge pour les femmes à venir
sans jugement de la société allez sam
mclaughlin ce que tu as lizzo
tu es le prochain rocky
je
suppose que je l'ai perdue ouais mais au moins
tu t'es battu tu as pris beaucoup de courage il
faudrait un faiseur de miracles pour m'aider je
pense que je connais juste le gars
qui est celui que tu veux me former
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je te veux  pour m'entraîner, t'entraîner à
faire du vélo, je  je fais partie d'un
club de combat qui semble dangereux
j'en ai marre que mes démons s'améliorent contre moi
et je veux
les frapper au visage
je t'aime bien heidi anna d'accord allons-y avec
ça
tu ne frappes même pas comme une fille  tu frappes
comme un chat comme un chat qui ne peut pas boxer
oh
un endroit comme ça devrait être une vraie
compétition avec de vrais combattants
elle bouge comme néo dans la matrice je n'ai pas
peur de toi cobra kai
mieux vaut surveiller ton dos ouais eh bien tu
ferais mieux  regarde tes
parties avant ce joli visage
va le perdre elle s'est retenue
je te verrai ici demain soir
tête haute
allons-y
maman jean c'est serré
[Musique
] c'est
unfou
[Rires]
toi